- [Narrator] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
Also, make sure to check out and subscribe
to our YouTube original
channel, UCTV Prime,
available only on YouTube.
(techno music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History,
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Jeff Hawkins,
who is the Hitchcock professor
on the Berkeley campus
in the spring of 2012.
Jeff Hawkins is an inventor,
engineer, neuroscientist,
author and entrepreneur.
He founded both Palm
Computing and Handspring,
created the Redwood Neuroscience Institute
to promote research on
the brain and cognition,
and is a member of the scientific board of
Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory.
He authored on Intelligence,
which was written
with Sandra Blakeslee.
And his latest company is Numenta,
which brings his two passions together:
study of the brain and the development
of intelligent machines.
Jeff, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you, it's a pleasure to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born on Long Island in New York.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- I had a pretty unusual childhood.
My father was sort of
the consummate inventor,
not particularly successful,
but I grew up in a house
where we were just building
crazy things all the time,
crazy boats and so on
and exposed to a lot of
different things as a child.
- Reading up on you, your father
and the family together
made floating boats?
- Well, he did lots of
things, my father did,
but one of the things he did,
he built a lot of unusual
craft, floating craft.
One was, at the time, the
largest air cushion craft,
it wasn't a hovercraft
but it was a round boat.
We eventually did some research,
eventually we sold it to an Orchestra
and a tour of an Orchestra
around New York City.
On this unusual thing, it
looked like a space craft.
And that's one of many projects,
but it was very influential as a child.
- And this must've made an important
both impression, but also,
way of learning a lot of skills
that became useful later.
- It did.
There's no question about it
that I had exposure to a lot of tools,
a lot of different environments.
We weren't a wealthy family at all,
we were kinda living on the edge
of lower-middle class I would say.
But I had a wealth of
different experiences.
At the time I didn't really
understand the value of that,
but later in life it became clear
that it really did help me in many ways.
- And it's not just the practical element
of working with tools,
but to the extent that
you seem to be saying
that your father would
envision things that weren't there before.
- Yeah, I'll tell you a story.
When I was in third grade,
there was a thing called a Weekly Reader,
I don't know if that still exists.
- [Harry] Oh yeah, of course.
- And third grade, my father's
on the cover of Weekly Reader
and he had an invention at
the time called a Septron,
which was a type of pattern recognizer,
and there he was with a
microphone talking to a dolphin.
You know, this was very
unusual for a third-grader
to have this kind of thing happen,
it was always exposed to
these kind of unusual things.
- And so what was the discussion
at the dinner table like?
Was it about "Well how
do we fix this boat?"
or "How do we design this project?"
- It was a mixed thing.
It was definitely a lot of, like,
"Let's go back out to the
garage and work on something
right after dinner."
And in our house, actually the garage
was the warmest part of the house,
so in the winter that was where we went.
I wouldn't say it was a very
philosophical upbringing.
I was brought up in a
secular, atheist home
and we just discussed world matters a bit.
My father subscribed to
Scientific American from a child,
and so those were always in the house
and I read them religiously every month.
I still do that.
There was a culture of,
hey, the world is
interesting, let's explore it.
- Where did you do your...
Well let's talk about when
you were in high school.
Did you do a lot of
science in high school?
And where did you do
your undergraduate work?
- In high school I was...
I never really worked particularly hard.
I always did well.
And so to me high school was
more of a matter of, like,
hey, let's find something fun to do
while I have to take these classes.
So I did computer projects,
I was often given leeway to do very,
actually sometimes excuse
myself from things in physics.
And so I could just do what I wanted to.
So I kinda cruised through that,
and then I went to Cornell University.
It really wasn't much of a choice.
I just said "Hey, I am living in New York.
"That's a place I can get scholarships
"and it's a good university,
"and so that's where I'm gonna go."
- And what did you major in?
- Electrical engineering.
I didn't have a passion for that,
but I remember, again, this is
something from my father's influential.
I was thinking about getting
into alternative energy,
this is in, you know, the mid-seventies.
And he said, "You know,
this computer stuff
"looks pretty interesting,
these microelectronics.
"Why don't you think about that?"
Okay.
- And then, from there, but
was it there that you got
what we might call the neuroscience bug?
- No.
- [Harry] No?
- No, it wasn't.
It was right after I graduated,
and I graduated in the spring of 1979,
in the fall of 1979, there
was a single topic issue
of Scientific American,
every September issue,
and it was about the brain.
This was one of the best
issues they've ever had,
lots of other neuroscientists
will say the same.
Reading that issue is
really what ignited my
interest in brains.
- Anything in particular that struck you?
You seem to be saying that the Crick essay
was really important.
- Yes, it was.
So, like a lot of people I read it.
We're all interested in the brain, right?
Who wouldn't be interested in the brain?
It's who we are.
And so with all these details,
and you can read about the
neurons and this and this,
and then the last essay
was by Francis Crick,
of DNA fame, and he wrote an
essay of something called like
Thinking About Thinking,
I think it was called.
And he said, "This is all well and good,
"we have all this data,
lots of data, data, data,"
he says, "but we have no theory here."
There's been no assimilation to this data
into a theoretical framework,
and it struck me like a bolt of lightning.
I said, "Wow, what a great problem."
We have the data, we
don't have the theory,
it's not like we're starting from scratch.
I said, "This is something
we can do in my lifetime."
And I just decided right then and there
that I was gonna dedicate my life to that.
- And then as you're looking
to do advanced graduate work,
you had interesting experiences both with
MIT and with Berkeley.
Talk a little about that,
because it seems to be important.
- Yeah, so I said, okay.
I was working in industry
as a computer engineer
and I said, "Well, I
really wanna do brains,
"so I need to go back to school.
"I need a research curriculum in my life."
So I first applied to MIT,
which had the AI Lab, and I said,
"Well they wanna build
intelligent machines,
"they must be interested
in how intelligence works."
So I applied there, and they said,
"Yeah, we wanna build
intelligent machines,
"but brains don't matter."
And, literally, one of
the faculty said to me,
"Brains are just messy computers,
"so why bother studying them?
"We're not interested in brains here,
"you can't do that here."
And I thought that was wrong,
but as a young person I was
devastated of being rejected.
But I said, "Okay, pick
myself up and I'll try again."
A few years later I got myself into
a biophysics program at Berkeley,
which was the closest I could get
to theoretical neuroscience,
there wasn't any theoretical
neuroscience back then.
And I to study a lot of biology,
I didn't have that in my background,
so I did a lot of prep for this.
I got in here and so I
was a graduate student
at Berkeley starting in
1986, very beginning of 1986.
But I quickly found out,
about five months into it,
that I wouldn't be able to do
what I wanted to do here, either.
- You reached some conclusions
about the academy from that.
Is that fair, a fair statement?
- You mean the academy of Berkeley or--?
- Just the academy
generally, in other words,
here you are, a young guy who's saying,
says, "Hey, I wanna do this from
"an entirely different approach,"
and two of the top places
in the country said,
"Well we can't do that here."
- Yeah, what was interesting
about Berkeley was
it was a bit more sympathetic.
The reaction I got from faculty was,
"This is great!
"We need to be doing this.
"It's great that you wanna,
and you have good ideas.
"But you can't do it."
And so I realized at that time,
and the reason why I couldn't do it
was because there was no faculty doing
very close to what I wanted to do.
And I didn't really understand
that when I came to Berkeley.
And so, it struck me as, "Oh wow,
"there's a whole different
aspect to the problem."
I realized I wasn't just up
against a scientific problem,
but I had an institutional problem.
If people agreed that this
was a good thing to do,
and they tell you you can't do it,
that's an institutional problem.
And I have to address that issue as well.
- Somewhere, maybe it was
in the book on intelligence,
you suggest that one of the things
about the academic environment was
it's reluctant to take risk.
Is that a fair statement?
- That was something I was
told over and over again.
I might've concluded that on my own,
but it's not something I felt.
Other people told me
that, they'd explain why.
It was interesting, later in life
when I started the Redwood
Neuroscience Institute,
I had a chance to go visit
NIH and NSF and DARPA.
I had a good inside person on my board,
so we got to meet with all
the top program directors
in neuroscience at NIH,
and the program directors at NSF,
and I told them about my
interest in, you know,
why I'm starting an institute.
I said, "I'm not raising money,
"I want to talk to you about working,
"about how we're gonna develop
models of the neocortex."
And they were like, "This is great!
"This is wonderful.
"We need this, we need
this, we need this."
And then the NIH program
director started saying,
"Unfortunately, we can't do any of this.
"And here's why we are
unable to fund these
"kinds of research."
Not just me, I wasn't asking for funding.
They're saying why they can't fund
other people who want to do this.
And it was very, very interesting
to learn about why it was so difficult
for neuroscientists to incorporate
a theoretical paradigm into their work.
And there's all these different
forces which were making it
difficult for people to do this.
- What in particular?
- I think there's several things.
One is, at this time, things
have changed now a bit,
but back then there wasn't a long history
of theory in neuroscience.
There wasn't a long history of
theory in biology in general,
but that changed,
but in neuroscience it
was later to change.
It was originally a
classification science.
So a lot of the old guard, if you will,
looked down upon theoretical things,
like, this is about animal studies,
write labs, there's no
room for theory here.
Then, the way funding came about,
this is what I heard from
the NIH directors is that
the way their funding, it's a very
consensus, peer-review process.
And since money is tight,
nobody wants to take a risk on anything,
which is slightly speculative.
I can totally understand this,
there's no anger about this.
Just, this is the way the world was.
So it was interesting to learn all these
forces that were at play there.
- And at this point in
your career you decide
to go into the world of computers,
Silicon Valley, and to
become an entrepreneur,
inventor, and thinker there.
And your goal here was to, what?
- So let me tell you,
So I was a graduate student at Berkeley.
And I'd been here for a while,
and basically I was told, "You
can't do what you wanna do."
I had a choice, I could do something else
as a graduate student
related in neuroscience.
But I looked at that and I said,
"That's not gonna work for me.
"I'm gonna get stuck
doing this other thing,
"and I won't be able to actually end up
"doing the thing I wanted to do."
So I was very bummed out about this,
and so I had to sort of reset my life.
And I said, "What am I gonna do?
"I have to do something."
So I said, "Okay, I'm
going to go back and work."
I'd already been working in computers
for a number of years before
I became a graduate student at Berkeley.
So I'd given up my career to
become a graduate student.
And I said, "I'm gonna go
back into the computer field."
I thought I would do it for four years,
and I had several goals.
One goal, as I said, look,
I'm up against an institutional problem.
So I need to learn about institution.
How do I affect broader issues?
So I said, "Well, you
know, building a business
"or running a company is a good way
"of sorta learning how to be
"a more influential person in the world."
The second thing I said,
"Well neuroscience is gonna progress,
"and maybe people will
become more amenable
"to the approaches that I wanted to do."
Another thing, I just said,
"Well, maybe if I make a
little bit of a name for myself
"it'll open some doors."
"And finally I said, "If I
could put some money in the bank
"then I can afford to be a student again
"'cause I'm starting to raise a family
"and I can't really, you know,
be... I have to live a life."
So I said, "Okay, I'll try
to do that in four years."
And I, very lucky, I was lucky in my work
and I was able to be
successful in many ways.
It turned out that, and
I loved normal computing,
and I thought, "this is a
great thing to work on."
After I got into it, it was very difficult
to extract myself from it.
I'll tell you a little story.
When I started Palm,
and I had to raise money
from venture capitalists,
I actually put it in the
founding documents of Palm
that my real interest was neuroscience.
And that my goal in a
few years was to go back
and work in neuroscience.
They were worried that I was
gonna abandon this right away,
so I said, "Okay, I'm gonna
put in a number of years here,
"and then, but everyone
knows after those years
"I can start spending some
time in neuroscience again."
Well it turned out that
the success of Palm,
and those ventures really kinda built
and I got swept away and
it was very difficult
to extract myself from it.
It took me quite a few
years to really get myself
completely out of it again.
- When you look at your career,
you had an important insight.
As I understand it, that insight was
on the one hand I wanna study and make
and build intelligent machines.
But to do that, the model to
look at is how the brain works.
Is that a fair statement of the two ideas
that have motivated you?
- It's a fair statement of the two ideas,
but they came in a different order.
My first love was, and is, the brain.
I wanna understand how my brain works.
I wanna understand how your brain works.
Humanity, we are brains.
Everything we do, our
conversation, our science,
our literature, our history, our art
it's a product of brains.
And our knowledge of the world,
our ability to ask questions of the world
is what brains do.
If I wanna understand
our place in the universe
I have to understand what brains are.
So this to me was a
pure love of knowledge.
I then quickly said,
"Well, if we figure out how brains work,
"we can build machines that
work on those principles."
And that's the way to build
truly intelligent machines.
That wasn't my number one
motivation, it still isn't,
and now I've come to understand that's a
very important thing to do as well,
so the order is a little different,
but the two go hand-in-hand.
You can't really do one without the other.
- Setting out on this course in that order
that you just described,
meant you wound up
wearing a lot of hats.
And I'm curious because
students watch this interview
so I'm curious as to what the
skills required, on one hand,
to be a theorist, then an engineer,
an inventor, and an entrepreneur.
And the other hand, the
temperament that's involved.
Now, what I wanna ask you is,
is there overlap in these different roles
are not as different as we think?
- The roles are pretty different.
But there is a common theme.
And the common theme is I had
very clear long-term goals.
And I was persistent.
And if, to get to my long-term goals
I had to start a company,
I'm gonna start a company.
It's not easy.
It is a lot of work.
It is filled with anxiety
and problems and bad days.
To see my goals, I had to
start a neuroscience institute.
How do you start a new institute?
Who's gonna be the first one to show up?
Do you put a sign on the street
and say, "Come to my institute"?
So these are difficult problems,
but in the end I had
clear goals in my life
and it's just a matter of persistence
if I have to learn something totally new.
I had to learn how to make cell phones.
I didn't know how to make cell phones.
I built one of the first smart phones.
I had to learn how to do that.
I had to learn how to start companies.
I had to learn how to run an institute.
I had to learn how to interact
with academic environments
and give talks and so on.
But it's all towards a goal.
I won't say it was all easy,
it was actually quite difficult.
But you have that
long-term goal and you say,
"Okay, life's challenging,
these are difficult obstacles,
"but I think I can overcome them."
Just keep going.
Just don't give up.
- So what you're describing in addition is
it takes courage to do this, is that--?
- I won't use that word,
if you want to use that word that's fine.
I think persistence is the right thing.
It's the never give up.
I remember once I gave a talk at UC Davis.
And I rode in the car with
a friend of mine who is a
scientist who studies earthquakes.
And here I was, a computer entrepreneur,
and I was going to give a talk to a
neuroscience department about brains.
And he was like, he was astounded.
He said, "You feel
comfortable doing that?"
And he says, "Are they gonna respect you?"
You know, "What are your
credentials for doing this?"
And he thought this is
like so gutsy or so crazy.
And I'm like, well, what
else am I going to do, right?
So there's this sort of attitude,
and it's a little awkward at first.
You get up there and, "Who's this guy?"
and "Why is he talking to us?"
and maybe I don't speak
the same language they do.
That's often the case,
especially in a complex
field like neuroscience
there's lots of different languages
and different approaches people take.
But you just plow forward
and you just have to go with the punches.
- What in your formative
experiences made you this way?
- I remember my parents trying
to tell me about Santa Claus as a kid.
And I immediately said,
"That's not possible.
"I just don't believe that."
And--
(Harry laughs)
I had a problem as a child,
which my mother took me to a doctor
to see if it was something wrong with me.
The problem was that I would
hear what I expected to hear
and not what people were actually saying.
I literally, you'd say a sentence to me
and I would hear it as what I
thought you were going to say.
It was so problematic
at times my mother said,
"Maybe there's something
wrong with your hearing."
And I internalized this, said,
"You know what, I just
have a model of the world.
"I have this expectation
of what's going to happen,
and that's so strong it drives me."
So it was a very internally
focused view of the world
and I think that stuck
with me for my whole life.
- You are a theorist in a field
that didn't have a theory.
So in understanding you
would actually get some
important insights about theorizing.
And going back to the Crick article,
in other words, the theorist's problem is
that there's a lot of data coming in
from different streams of information.
And in the end, there is no
big explanatory understanding.
Talk about theorizing, 'cause this is
a very different cult
than being an engineer.
- So, when I realized I had
this institutional problem,
like being a theorist in a
field that doesn't have theory,
I went back and studied the
history of scientific ideas.
I went back and read Thomas Kuhn
and The History of Scientific Revolutions.
I tried to figure, "What happens here?
"How do you go about this?"
And that was actually very useful for me.
Because Kuhn talks about what
you do differently in science
when you're working in a field
that doesn't have a paradigm.
And you have to sorta be
a little bit different.
He talks about how the way you publish
and the way you interact
and how scientists conduct in science.
So I took that as sort of,
"Great, I can be a little different here."
I might have to take different approaches.
I might have to publish
this as a popular book
as opposed to a scientific
paper and so on.
And so I took that process,
I really sorta thought about the process
of what you'd have to do about this.
And it led me down various paths
that I might not have done otherwise.
- In your lecture yesterday,
in the introduction
you said that when you realized
you couldn't do a PhD at Berkeley,
you took a year to go to the library.
Talk a little about that, because--
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- ...in other words,
you had to master the field--
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- ...that is the information side.
- So I came to Berkeley, the
first thing I wanted to do
is I wanted to sign up.
I said, "These are all the neuroscience
classes I wanna take."
And my first disappointment was they said,
"You can't take them.
"You have to take this
biochemistry class."
As I said I couldn't
craft my own curriculum.
So I said, "All right,
I'll do those things."
And then I took Jeffrey
Weiner's anatomy class,
which was like, "Great,
"this is the best thing in the world."
And I just immersed myself in it.
But when I found that I couldn't really do
what I wanted to do, I said,
"Okay, well I've quit my
job, I'm here, what do I do?"
I said, "Let me make my own education."
And so I spent a year, about 12 months,
coming, I had a student pass
but I wasn't taking any classes
or had very little interaction
with anyone at the university.
But I'd go to the
libraries here once a week
with a list of papers I wanna read.
I would look up those papers,
cause there was no Internet, right?
It's all paper in some library someplace,
and I look at the journal and I say,
"Okay, that's a good one."
Or, "That's not a good one."
And then I photocopied
a whole bunch of these.
I had a card and I'd come
up with a stack of papers,
literally a stack of papers
several inches thick every week.
I'd go home and I'd read them.
And some of them were
very, very hard to read.
Some papers are very obtuse
and the language isn't simple.
And so I did this over
and over again every week,
and then I would mark which references
I wanted to follow up on.
Then I'd go back to the library
and I would go through those again,
I would spend the day
reading here, basically.
And then I'd go home again,
I lived about an hour away.
I did this for about a year,
and I just built my own view
of what the world of neuroscience is.
I also read linguistics
and some philosophy
and some psychology.
Anyone who I thought might have
tangential relationship
to how the brain works.
And I made my own view of
all these different fields.
Which ones are speaking to me as like,
yeah, these are on the right track
and these are not on the right track.
I think that was a luxury that
most young people don't
have an option to do.
They get down a track
and they're in some lab
and they learn the language of that lab.
But to be able to do this
sort of self directed
study was, and there's a huge amount
of neuroscience research, so
that was a really unusual thing.
- So in a way, opting out
or being forced to opt out
of graduate school was a blessing.
- Well, it didn't look it at the time.
I'll be honest with you.
In hindsight you could say that.
I was kinda hoping I would be
able to do that as a student,
as a graduate student, right?
I would be encouraged to do this.
I would be someone saying,
"Here's some suggestions."
But in the end it was what I needed to do,
and it was a great thing to do.
I just read voraciously in the field.
- So you leave graduate school,
you already mentioned you went out
and developed some products.
I wanna, as we are understanding
the different hats you've worn,
you had a sense of the
importance of mobile devices
and what they could mean
for business and the world
if people in the field could actually
gather this data and it could be mastered.
- Well, I did have, in about 1991,
I sorta had an epiphany
about mobile devices.
Now I had worked for a
company called Grid Systems,
and we had built mobile computers,
they invented a laptop.
But I had this sort of
epiphany about the future of
pocket-sized computers, mobile devices.
And I said "Oh my goodness, in the future
"everyone's primary computer
is gonna be in their pocket."
And this is the way we
can bring the benefits
of computers to billions of people.
'Cause in that time it
was very, very expensive
and difficult to maintain these things.
It took lots of power and
they're very complex machines.
I said, "No, it's gonna be simple.
"They're gonna be in your pocket.
"They're gonna be inexpensive,
"billions of people around
the world can have them."
This sounded crazy at the time.
Because back then there was no Internet,
no web browsers, there was
no wireless data networks,
no one was using a cellular phone,
in the United States at least.
There was no technology for doing this,
there was no battery, the
memory technology didn't exist.
None of this existed.
And people said, "What are you gonna do
"with this mobile device?"
I couldn't even answer
that question, I said,
"I just know it's gonna happen."
I could see this.
Inevitable more and more,
people are gonna access information
with these things in their pocket.
So it sounded kinda crazy.
And I used to talk about
this in my VP Marketing,
they said, "Jeff, stop talking about that.
"It sounds stupid."
But I believed it and I
said, "It's gonna happen."
I said, "This is a good thing.
"And this is a good thing to go after.
"This is a good thing to do."
I thought it was gonna be
really good for the world.
And I thought, "Okay, that's a thing
"to work on for a few years.
"And let's see if we can
make progress on that."
And we succeeded, I think we succeeded
where a lot of other companies failed.
There's a lot of failures in this space.
We succeeded I believe because
I had that long-term vision.
It wasn't like I was
building this or that,
I was like, "No, we're
bringing computers to billions
"of people and this is the
attributes it has to have.
"Therefore this is going to happen."
So, regardless of our failures
we can continue working on this
because it's going to happen.
And we were lucky we actually did succeed,
in a big way, actually.
- It's funny, as I listen to you,
you combine academic skills
without being an academic.
And then with a very interesting
set of people skills,
and a kind of sonar
mechanism for understanding
what's going on in the
world and changing it.
Is that fair?
- I guess in hindsight you could say,
it's like, yeah, I think it's fair.
I didn't view it that way.
I was viewing it like,
"I wanna do something.
"This is important.
"What do I gotta do?"
- So, you founded this institute
and ultimately you gave
the institute to Berkeley.
But what were the difficulties
of founding an institute
in a field that was not yet recognized?
- Well, it was interesting,
the idea for setting the
institute was not mine.
I had a bunch of neuroscience friends
and they were sympathetic with my goals
of understanding neocortical theory.
They understand the difficulties,
why this is hard to do,
why you can't get funding for this.
And some of them suggested, "You know,
"the way to do this is
to create an institute."
And I said, "Oh yeah," like,
"Sure, that's gonna be easy."
That sounds like impossible, right?
It wasn't impossible from
a funding point of view,
because I could actually fund it myself.
I was lucky to be wealthy
at that time from my work.
But it was more like,
"How do I structure this?"
"How do I get respect for this?"
"Who's gonna wanna work there?"
So on, so I said to a
bunch of neuroscientists,
I said, "Look, I will
do this if you help me.
"If you will bring people and ideas
"and help me get through these problems."
And one of the people I talked to was
Bob Knight at Berkeley,
who was the head of the
Helen Wills Neuroscience
Institute at the time.
And he said, "Okay, I'll help you."
And a few other people did the same,
so I said, "Okay, we'll get going."
The problems were, first of all there's
all these logistical things,
which is like starting a business.
We've gotta have a location,
you gotta have a corporate structure,
you gotta have boards, advisory boards,
you know, legal documents,
and pay salaries,
and these things take a lot of time.
And then there's like,
how are you gonna structure the science?
And who's going to work there?
Under what terms?
So, it got going in fits and starts.
After we got going it turned out that the
Redwood Neuroscience Institute became
the hot place to be.
People started hearing
about it around the world
and the best thing we did is we had
every week, we brought
in outside speakers.
We'd fly people and we'd say,
"Who do we wanna hear from?"
We wanna study the basal ganglia?
Who's the best basal gangliar person?
Who's gonna tell us?
And we'd say, "We wanna
hear from this person."
Sometimes we'd fly them in,
we'd pay their way, we'd say,
"You guys are gonna give a talk
and we're gonna grill you."
They were very unusual the talks at the
Redwood Neuroscience Institute
because usually scientists
are very polite.
So they'd come in and we'd have
20 or 25 people in the room,
and we would just tear into them.
Not in a mean way, but in a great way.
Like, explain this more.
We didn't understand this in your paper.
And people over and over said,
"My God, you really care
about what I'm doing.
"You've read my papers."
Word spread that getting an invitation
to the Redwood Neuroscience Institute
was something to be had.
And so over the course of
the three years that I ran it
we had over 100 visitors,
about 120 I think it was.
And it became sort of
a cool little hot spot
in the neuroscience world for
people who cared about this.
- And interestingly,
obviously it was your money,
the fact that you put
in place an institution.
But really, it was the mission statement
that was really important.
We're gonna look at what you're saying,
but not tied to the detail.
How can what you're saying
impact the big picture?
Is that fair?
- Yeah, yeah it is fair.
And what we did, everyone knew
the mission of the institute.
It is neocortical theory.
I also told them right upfront,
this is not a place to retire.
This is a place to work on that problem.
And I'm not guaranteeing your
job for any amount of time.
'Cause I knew I didn't
wanna run an institute
for the rest of my life.
I said, "As long as we're
making progress in this problem,
"you know you're welcome to be here."
And I said, "You can do anything you want,
"but here's the things,
"you have to attend every
lecture from an outside speaker.
"You have to journal club.
"And you have to
participate in these things,
"it's not optional to do those things."
And everyone collectively is gonna say,
"Is your work contributing
to that broader mission?"
But other than that, you
can do whatever you want.
You can publish or not publish,
you can travel, you can
do whatever you want.
So that's how I set it up,
and it was an unusual structure
for a research institute.
And some of it worked and
some of it didn't work,
but some parts were very successful.
- Your mission statement involved
a focus on the neocortex.
Explain to our audience: why that focus?
Why is the neocortex so
important, and what is it?
- Mammals have a neocortex, all mammals.
Non-mammals don't.
In humans and other animals
of high intelligence
it's very big.
So in the human brain it's about
60 percent of the volume of your brain.
If you look at a brain
it's the big wrinkly thing
that covers everything else.
It's like a big sheet of cells
that wraps around the rest of the brain,
which is actually pretty small.
And why it's so important is because
it is the locus of intelligence.
All language, spoken,
written, mathematics, physics,
music, whatever, it's all
a product of the neocortex.
Both production of it
and understanding it.
All high level vision
and all high level motor planning.
The rest of the brain
is very, very important
to being human, it does a lot of stuff.
But when we think about, you know,
when we're talking about discovering
the properties of the world
or communicating through language
or the conversation you
and I are having right now,
it's the neocortex.
And so my goal is a, that
was the most interesting part
of the brain to focus on
if you wanna understand
what intelligence is,
and also, it turns out
that it is, in some ways,
one of the most regular
parts of the brain.
That is, even though
it's very, very large,
it's much more, it's not homogenous,
but it is a repeated structure
over and over and over again.
With the other parts of the brain
have been around for a much longer time
in evolutionary time and
they're highly evolved.
So you've got highly
evolved things for emotions
and highly evolved things for
auditory location and so on,
but the neocortex appeared big recently.
It just like, boom!
And so it had this regular structure,
so the idea was like, you could figure out
principles of how the neocortex works
which supplies to all high
level thought processes.
I don't need to have a theory of vision
and a theory of language and a theory of
how the brain does physics.
It's really all the same thing,
this is a miraculous
discovery, it's not mine,
but it's a miraculous discovery.
And I said, "Wow, great!
"This is the center and it's a possibility
for finding out a few key principles,
and when you figure out those principles
you can explain a lot.
- And so how did you go about
discovering those principles or finding
who had talked about those principles?
It's not as if you found them new.
- Well, there's clues everywhere.
First of all, very, very
few people have that focus.
They're not even looking for those things.
And so the clues are embedded
in all these different disciplines
about when people write
a little bit about this
and a little bit about that,
and a large part of the
problem that I faced
was what to ignore.
The field of neuroscience has so much data
on so many things and
so many different ideas.
It's unbelievable how
much has been published
in this field, you can't get a sense of it
until you try to do a broad
research literature study.
So a lot of it was, like,
sorting through the noise
and figuring out where are the gems here.
Where are the key ideas?
And then you take those key ideas,
and that's a hit-and-miss process.
Perhaps it involves some skill,
it certainly involves an opinion
about how to go about that, and my opinion
is different than other people's opinion,
but I trusted my instincts on this.
And then I'd say, "Okay, now
we have these core pieces that
I'm gonna ignore all these
other things for now,
How do I assemble those
into a certain theoretical framework?
Some of it was out there, kinda hidden.
Some of it I had to come up with myself.
- And the purpose of a
theory, going back to Kuhn,
a paradigm, is to in a way
give us a simple statement
that tells us which data is important
and lays out a model or a paradigm.
- Yes, yes.
And that's what I'm trying
to do in my life's work.
And my talk yesterday, I talked about it.
I said, "What is the framework?"
And I even listed out principles.
I said, "These are the some
of the key principles, I believe in."
And here's the language
I use to describe them,
because that's another problem.
Because everybody has different language
for the same, similar ideas.
That's what I'm trying to do,
and I view it that way
and I often begin my talks
with that quote from Francis Crick about
where he talks about
we're missing a framework,
which is essentially
the same as principle.
We're missing a framework for
understanding these ideas.
And I constantly ask myself,
"How are we doing on that?"
I think we're making a lot of progress,
I'm very pleased with it from
where I started I'm thrilled.
- Give us a rundown of some of the
core principles you've come upon.
We don't have visuals and our
audience is a public audience
and it may be students
who would be interested.
So simply stated, what are the core--
- Let me go down a few of them,
some of the very basic ones.
One thing that a lot of
people confuse about it
is the brain is not like a computer.
The brain is a memory system.
It's about storing
patterns from the world,
not computing, you don't compute
how to move your arm to catch a ball.
You actually recall sequences of patterns
that have been stored previously
and you're recalling them
in a sort of novel way.
So it's all about memory,
it's a memory organ.
And it has to be trained,
and it has to be trained
from sensory data.
No one goes in and drops
the memory in there,
it's like you have these
senses of the world
and our problem is figuring out how
from the sensory stream
coming into the neocortex
how it builds a model of the world.
The second really big insight,
which was at first understood,
well a couple of people involved in this.
Mountcastle, Edelman,
and Van Essen and others.
Essentially, the neocortex
has its most basic structure
it's a hierarchy of memory regions.
And so, even though it
looks like a sheet of cells,
actually these sheets
are connected together
and in certain regions you can logically
think of them as a hierarchy.
And that's a real thing,
that's not a debatable thing.
It's a physical fact.
And so now we have, oh,
it's a different type of memory system.
It's a hierarchical memory.
We don't really have
hierarchial memory systems
in computers or elsewhere,
that's a new idea.
And I'll tell you two more ideas.
The next one is that each of
those regions in the hierarchy
no matter what they're doing,
vision, language, touch,
you know, motor, whatever,
they're all doing the same principle.
This is one of those "aha" moments
this came from Mountcastle
and a few other people around 1979,
which was like, "Oh my goodness,
"this is one of those beautiful things
"we've discovered about nature."
When you think you have
all these different things,
but they're really one in the same.
Vision is the same as audition,
which is the same as somatosensory sets,
it is the same thing.
There's huge amounts of evidence for this,
and yet some people have
trouble believing it.
They just, "I can't believe it's true."
It's true.
And then the final thing
was an insight that I had
and I'm not saying other
people didn't have it,
but it was a real new thing for me.
Was that what's going on in these regions
in this hierarchy of cortical regions,
is that it's the fundamental
memory principle,
the memory property,
is memory of sequences.
Of how things move
through time in the world.
What follows what, what words I say next.
Everything I'm doing here
is a playback of sequences.
You're recognizing sequences of patterns.
Audition, touch, and even vision,
it's all about time-based patterns.
And so, how does the
brain learn sequences?
I've been spending the
last seven years on that,
we've made really good progress on that.
- You used the term
yesterday in the lecture,
"spatially distributed representation."
- [Jeff] Sparsely distributed.
- Sparse, yeah, sorry, sparsely, yes.
- We've known for a long time
that when you look at
the cells in the brain,
the brain is just made
of a bunch of cells,
it's just neurons, lots of
'em, but they're just cells.
When you look at the brain,
a normal, healthy brain,
you find that at any moment in time,
very few of those cells are active
and most of them are silent.
And this has been known,
there's empirical evidence,
and not many people
thought too hard about it.
Some people have and they say,
"Well maybe there's some efficiencies
and energy usage and blah blah blah."
But we now have a deep
theoretical understanding,
and part of this came from other people,
part of it came from myself.
A deep theoretical understanding
of why it's sparse.
It's not just about saving energy
or some sort of efficiency,
there are fundamental
information properties
that come out of having a
representation of the brain
where you have a few things active
and both things inactive and
then you change over time.
So it's a temporarily point,
you know all the cells become
active at some point in time,
but it's very sparse, and you
don't see a lot of the cells
active at the same time.
And so there's these deep
information principles,
which I now understand
the significance of.
And they tell me now
that all intelligence,
whether it's biological
or machine or human-made,
it doesn't matter, all intelligence
can be based on sparse representations.
I can be certain of that now.
And so this has become a
bit of a rallying point
for me and some other
people to talk about that.
- Two other points that come out
in your book and in the lecture.
One is that it's a hierarchical system,
but the flows of information go both ways.
And the upper regions are the keeper
of the models or the patterns,
but those can change as
there is input of data.
- Well, it's not quite
like that, it's close.
They're all learning
patterns in this hierarchy,
and the way the system works is
when I wanna take an input stream,
the lower the ones that the input,
parts of the neocortex
closest to the input
are learning patterns of
small parts of input space.
They're, like, in primary visual area
it's learning sequences of
little line movements and so on.
As you go up the hierarchy
it's sort of aggregating these
and it builds representations over it.
You can think of that as
you go up the hierarchy
it's assimilating knowledge from a broader
and broader part of the input space,
and over more and more time.
So you're ending up with
representations that are
representing longer periods of time
and more stable over
variations in the world.
So at the bottom of the visual hierarchy
I'll find little line segments,
but at the top I'll
find cells that respond
to faces and people and things like this.
They're all doing the same thing,
they're all learning sequences,
but there's this sort of collapsing
or a converging of these
things as you go up.
And then it unfolds, too.
So then think about my speech right now,
I'm producing a very high velocity,
meaning rapidly changing pattern.
In a matter of milliseconds
my muscles are going (nonsensical
noise) all over the place.
I'm recalling a sequence, a pattern,
that's coming out of my neocortex.
My whole brain is doing this.
There's parts of the low
down in the hierarchy
that are playing back
these rapid sequences.
Then there's parts of the hierarchy
that are playing out, like,
"You need to say this word."
And then there's, "You
need to say this phrase."
Or, "Jeff, talk about sparse
distributed representations."
So like in a high level concept,
at the higher part of the hierarchy
would send unfolding
sequences, unfolding sequences,
produces this torrent of patterns
coming out of my musculature.
- You also talk about the
brain and its placidity.
So it can adapt, creating
new bundles of information.
- Yeah, well, it's a
learning system, right?
So, it has to adapt and
has to take in patterns.
As you're coming in it
has to constantly say,
"I'm trying to learn
something new all the time.
Think about the brain doesn't
get to store it someplace
and decide later if it wants to learn it.
It says, "It's here now,
I gotta learn what's
going on in the world."
And so, the word plasticity
refers to a couple of things.
First, the fact that
it's a learning system
and new connections are
being formed all the time.
And it also refers in the brain that
the brain can slowly rewire itself.
Not just from new connections,
but it can slowly rewire itself over time
so that it can form entirely
new sort of architectures.
And this is very well documented
in many types of studies.
So we have this system
which essentially says,
"Look, I'm constantly learning.
"I'm constantly trying to discover
"the patterns in the world.
"I'm constantly adapting
it's very fluid process."
But it's working on the same
principles all the time.
- An important point that you make,
and again I'm going through
some of the high points here
to interest our audience so
they'll go read your book
and follow your research.
But you're suggesting
that in the upper regions,
conclusions can be reached
with only part of the pattern.
Talk a little about that.
- Yeah, that's true.
Quite a few scientists
understand this issue
and have written about it
more eloquently than I have, actually.
But your perception of the world, like,
if you're watching this video.
Me and you sitting here
having this conversation
is actually largely a product
of the memory in your brain.
It's largely a product of the model
you've created of the world.
So you have a sensory
stream that's just coming in
and you can't really see that.
You don't really, you're not
able to perceive that actually.
We don't have an ability
to actually look at it
but we know what it looks
like from scientific studies.
It's a very impoverished
sense of the world.
It's like my eyes are
darting all over the place
looking at little pieces here and there.
But I have a perception
of you being stable.
Your whole body is here, but
if you actually could see
what's coming in to my optic nerve
it's like this highly
distorted little thing
going (nonsensical noise)
all over the place.
It's amazing that you seem
stable in front of me.
So the reason it is, is
that throughout childhood
and our early years of development,
we built this model of how the world is.
And the sensory data invokes the model.
So my perception of you as a whole human
is largely the fact of my model.
I actually am getting little
pieces of data about you,
which confirm my model all the time.
Yes, he still looks like a
person, he's got two hands,
and a head, and feet, and so on.
You're sitting in a chair.
And so my perception,
the highest levels of the
cortex are saying, "Yes."
You know?
"There you are."
And in reality what's invoking that model
is this sort of like
crazy changing pattern
and (nonsensical noise)
all over the place,
which is like invoking the model.
And the model is
constantly testing itself,
saying, "Okay, well, if it is a human then
"his tie oughta have a knot
"and his glasses oughta
have things over his ears."
I'm not conscious of this,
I'm not thinking about it,
but the brain is doing this all the time.
- The bottom line here is that
when you take all this together this is
a computational system.
Is that the way I wanna say it?
- I try to avoid to use computation,
because people think it's like a computer.
- [Harry] Yeah, I see.
- In the history, in my talk
today I'll talk about this,
the history of people thinking about
building intelligent machines
or what intelligence is,
is largely why people think of it
as a computational problem.
And they say, "Oh, I'll
apply algorithms to this."
But in reality it's not.
It's a memory problem.
Now the memory system is
a complex memory system,
hierarchy, sparse
distribution representations,
sequences, and so on.
It's not simple, it's not
like, "Oh, just put it
"down on a piece of tape."
Or, "Put it on a desk
or something like that."
It's a complex memory system
and the memory system
itself has properties
that you could call,
if you wanna call them
computational properties,
like the way the memory system works
it has certain rules and so on.
Fundamentally it's a memory system.
If you try to figure out how brains work
or what intelligence is or
build intelligent machines,
by saying, "Okay, it's
a bunch of algorithms.
"We're gonna program these algorithms."
You're just not gonna succeed.
- Now where do the emotions come in?
That's not the part of the system that is
the brain complex that you're looking at.
- Well exactly, so I've said, you know
the neocortex is about 60 percent
of the volume of a human brain.
There's a lot of other
important stuff to be a human.
And there are several
small areas of the brain
which really dictate emotions.
One famous one is the amygdala,
people may have heard about that.
It's a little almond-shaped type of thing.
It's not part of the neocortex,
it's an old structure, so emotions
are much older on evolutionary time.
Animals that don't have a
neocortex have emotions.
A lizard can be or an
alligator can be angry
or fight and flee and wanna
have sex and things like that.
And there's a relationship between those
emotional centers in the neocortex.
While I didn't talk about it yesterday
and it's not in most of our models,
it's important if you
wanted to make a human.
If you wanna just capture
the essence of intelligence,
I argue you don't need to model that.
So, for example, in a human
one thing that'll happen
if you have a very
emotionally salient event,
like something happened to
you that was very dangerous
and you almost died.
Your emotion centers
of the brain will say,
"Bing, bing, bing!"
They'll light up and
they'll say, "Remember this.
"This is the most important thing,
"if you ever see this again
you'll never forget this."
You know if you're ever in
a situation like that again
you're just gonna be fearful.
It tells the neocortex,
"Never forget this.
"Make this a permanent memory."
The neocortex itself is not evaluating
the emotional aspects, it's not saying,
"I know it's emotionally salient."
So that's the little
thing like the amygdala.
But it's telling the neocortex,
"You should recognize this scenario
"and tell me when you see it again."
If I wanted to build intelligent machines
that were very human-like, which I don't.
If that's what you wanted to do,
then you'd have to build
emotional capabilities
plus a lot of other stuff.
We'd have to build the whole brain.
If you're just trying to
build intelligent machines
that are useful tools for humanity,
then you don't have to necessarily
model all that, or maybe we'll do it
in a slightly different way.
- Your long-term plan was to
apply what you learn here,
which we've discussed in
a brief presentation here.
What are you trying to do
with your new company now?
- The new company is, it's kind of a,
it's part of the process of,
you know when I talked to
you earlier about, like,
okay, I have this big long-term goal.
I gotta figure out how
the neocortex works,
and build machines that work like that,
and promote these theories to
create a paradigm for this.
And the company is one aspect of that,
in the same way like I started
the Neuroscience Institute,
or the same reason why I wrote a book.
I wrote a book, not because
I wanted to be an author,
because I felt it was a tool to help me
towards the end goal.
And my company Numenta is in some sense,
and for me it plays another role.
It's saying, okay, if we figured out how
part of the neocortex
works, and I think we have,
a good portion of it.
How do I get people excited about this?
How do I get an interest in this?
Well I can publish scientific papers,
maybe I can write another
book, which I probably will do.
But there's a whole 'nother
world of people out there
I wanna get excited about this.
These are entrepreneurs, scientists,
engineers, and computer scientists.
So by creating a company,
if you can create a successful product,
that gets a lot of people's attention.
It's a real wake up call to people,
like wow, there's someone that's
making some money doing this over here.
As crass as it sounds,
that's the way it worked.
They'll say, "How did they do that?
"How did they make that work?
"That's pretty cool, you know.
"What's going on there?"
And I say, "Here it is."
I explained it, I've written it up,
you can read it about it today.
You can read a white paper on a website
which explains how all of this works.
And people will study that and they'll go,
"That's pretty cool, I
wanna understand that."
So it's a way of
proselytizing, if you will,
to a different audience.
Obviously a company has
to be successful to be,
you know it has to make
money to be successful.
It has a dual mission as
to be a successful company,
but the reason I started it
was as one more vehicle for promoting
concepts or a way of
thinking about the brain,
and it's importance for doing that.
- In the long-term possibilities here are
streams of data on weather,
demography, all sorts of things
that could make intelligent decisions
about the meaning of the data.
- Yeah, so if we're on a path to
building truly intelligent machines,
what can we do today?
What's really interesting
that I can do today?
We've identified an
opportunity at Numenta,
which I think is really exciting.
The world is full of data.
People hear about this,
these terms big data,
awash in data, the
number of amount of bytes
you've been storing every year is bigger
than the Library of Congress, it's crazy.
And people don't know what to do with it.
Well, think about that.
Streams of data coming from
sensors or from computers,
from cars, from streets, from everything.
That's just like the data
coming into the brain
from sensors, it's just a
monstrous stream of data.
So what we can do is we
can apply brain modeling
to these streams of data to
model the data in the world
and act on it immediately,
just like humans do.
So instead of like storing
the data someplace,
we stream it into product we call GRAU,
which is essentially a corticomodel.
The model builds a model of the world
using a neocortical algorithm,
and makes predictions about future events
and we can act on those events.
So I'll give you just one example.
Turns out that when we consume electricity
there's a lot going on behind the scenes,
most people aren't aware of.
Large consumers of electricity can
buy their electricity at different
rates throughout the day.
They can make future contracts, and say,
"I'll pay this amount
for this amount of energy
six hours from now."
And there's a thing
called the man response,
which is going on everywhere,
you're not aware of this.
If I could predict better
the energy consumption in buildings,
I can be more efficient
and I can help everyone,
it makes a more efficient marketplace.
And we can start doing
this on a more rapid basis.
This is one of many
areas we're looking at,
and what we can do is we
can do a better job of this
predicting, like, okay, how much energy
is Berkeley campus gonna
use six hours from now?
How much should they be paying for that?
Or should they do some things now,
like pre-cool some buildings,
which'll be cheaper than
cooling them in useless
energy than cooling them later.
When you start automating this,
then you can do this on a
building-by-building basis,
you can do it by a four-by-four basis,
you could it by a room-by-room basis.
It gives you the sense of
how technology progresses.
So that's one example,
but the general idea is
with this world awash of data,
how do we take advantage of it?
How do we build smarter
cars and smarter buildings
and smarter power grids?
And we can use brain
technology to do that.
So that's pretty exciting.
It's a long way from building like,
fully brilliant robots or, you know,
super intelligent machines.
But it's on the path,
it's not a digression,
it's on a continuum toward that path.
- You're uniquely placed
to answer this question,
reflecting on your own career,
but also the research you've done.
So, what is creativity?
- I have a very clear idea of that.
Right or wrong, I have a clear idea of it.
The first thing you have to dispel
this notion that creativity
is something special.
You're actually exhibiting it
every moment of your waking life.
You are never in the exact
same situation twice.
If I look at the patterns
coming on your nerve fibers,
from your eyes, your ears, and your skin,
it never repeats ever in your entire life.
You may think you've been sitting here
talking to me the whole time,
but if you actually looked at
the patterns on your vibes,
I'm moving a little bit,
you're changing a little bit.
It's constantly changing.
The miraculous thing is we
perceive the world as not changing.
We perceive it as something like,
oh, I know who you are,
even though I've never met you before.
I can see you, and you're still here.
Actually what we're doing all
the time at a very low basis,
we're saying, "Here's a
new pattern coming in,
"and I'm making predictions
based on my previous model
"of the world of what
you should behave like."
Creativity is that process.
We tend to think of it
at a much higher level.
So I'm looking at some patterns coming in
from some sensory astronomical data.
And I'm trying to figure
out what's going on here?
What could explain these shifts
in the frequencies I'm working on?
And so on.
It's a novel pattern, and what
we do when we're creative,
we make analogies to previous experience.
It may be a very subtle analogy,
it may not even be obvious to you,
but you say, "Oh, that's a
little like a pattern I saw
three years ago in this
other paper about genetics."
And you say, "Well, what
they learned in the genetics
"is that this is
typically what's going on,
"so maybe that process will apply here."
And if you look at them,
take, for example, the
scientific creativity process,
it's very obvious that's what people do.
We form knowledge about the world
and then we go one step further and say,
"Here's new pattern, I
don't know really understand
"what's going on in this new pattern."
And the brain says, "Well,
it's kinda like this one."
In my talk yesterday I talked about
the specific mechanisms for this.
I think I understand the
specific mechanisms for this.
So creativity is on a spectrum
from the everyday where
you're not even aware of it,
where I'm being creative
by recognizing you.
You wouldn't think this, but
my brain's being creative
by saying, "Oh, you know, there's Harry.
"I know what he's gonna do and
I think he's got these things
"and I know what's on your
papers, it's probably questions."
On thoughts, even though I can't see it.
So I'm being creative all the time,
I'm making predictions about
things I don't really know.
But when we bring it up to the
high level of the neocortex,
these very difficult patterns
which extend over long periods of time
or in very distant places,
then we're doing the same process.
Now, something like artistic creativity
is a little harder to understand.
But I think it's basically the same idea.
You're saying, even an artist will say,
"You know, this is the way we typically
"represent something in the art world,
"but I have another view from this
"part of my literature I've read,
"which is something and
I'm gonna combine the two
"and I'll create something new."
- One final question, how
would you advise students
to prepare for the future?
- I get this question a lot,
and actually I get students
asking me this a lot.
I get probably several emails
a week where someone says,
they'll say, "You've inspired me.
"What can I do to do these things?"
It's a very difficult question to answer,
'cause it's hard to give
very specific answers.
I can't say, "Well, go to this university
"and study here."
The answers I generally, the
general answer to this question
and for some it's unsatisfactory,
but it's the best I can do,
and I said this earlier.
You need to find something
you're passionate about,
that you really care about, that you say,
"You know, this is
really important to me."
I don't care what it
is, you figure that out.
And then be persistent and go
do whatever you have to do.
Because I'll tell you what'll happen,
you're gonna run into roadblock
after roadblock after roadblock.
And success in life is basically,
success in life, success in
business, and success in science
is essentially overcoming
roadblocks, one after another.
Solving problems, one after another.
And the only way to do that
is to have this bigger vision,
to say, "You know, I know
I have to put up with this
"right now because I'm going over there.
"And this is the way to get there so
"literally it looks hard right now."
That's like the biggest
uber advice I could give.
And I think if you talk to a lot of people
who have some level of
success in their life,
or accomplishment, they very
often say the same thing.
They'll say, "You know, I
knew what I wanted to do,
"and I just had to really be
persistent to getting there."
And that's a good life lesson I think.
- Jeff, on that note, thank you very much
for coming on our program.
It was a fascinating intellectual journey.
- I thank you.
It was great questions,
I enjoyed it very much.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(techno music)